[Music]
hey river babes
welcome to the Sweetwater secrets
preview show for episode 302 chapter
thirty-seven Fortune and men's eyes
I'm your host Liana Galera and I'm back
to bring you my three clues about the
next all-new episode plus we're doing a
trailer breakdown I've got more scoop on
that lingering supernatural question and
get ready for an exclusive interview
with Lily Reinhart talking about getting
Betty a pink serpent jacket so let's get
started
first up I want to take a look at some
of your hisses and kisses that you left
on the Sweetwater secrets after-show for
the season three premiere
by the way River babes holy crap you
left more than a thousand comments and
yes I read each and every one you guys
are hilarious
and passionate and notice everything and
your kisses and kisses are on point so I
love you to pieces okay love fest over
um
first up Elaine Moo Cuccia posted kisses
- every single characters glow up for
season 3 jeez and then she added heart
eyes emoji
um I know right everyone looked
incredible now who do you think had the
best glow up from season two I don't
know what's in the water at Riverdale
but it's keeping our thirst strong
meanwhile Kazi miller and a lot of other
commenters pointed out cheryl has called
Tony titi before that was it a new
nickname
sorry about that Shoni fans I guess I
was just so disappointed that we're
barely featured our girls then I was
grasping to find anything new to hold on
to and I was wrong sigh meanwhile
Beatrice Hallberg wrote hisses to Kevin
for pushing moose not realizing that he
kind of just lost his girlfriend and she
didn't quote just died she was murdered
and hung up for everyone to see during
the musical not cool he and Beatrice
okay you're right
rest in peace midge but I still think
the Kevin Keller deserves better don't
at me actually do because I'm dying to
hear it you guys think maybe we'll go
after her next commenter Lea Street also
noticed something great and said so
first of all Polly was
for over nine months and then the babies
don't even grow like WTF I think we can
all agree that time moves very weirdly
in Riverdale and Alexandra taught to
mock oh sorry for my setup girl added
many many many kisses to my favour
Annika for telling Hyrum he has no
daughter anymore you don't have a
daughter anymore yes I was savage and I
loved it
and coachella great handle wrote kisses
to Leanne for this new show and the new
set Riverdale is so ridiculous so we
need an outlet like this for the sake of
sanity thanks girl yeah this season is
going to get even crazier so I'm glad
we're all on this together
there were also a lot of comments about
the supernatural elements in the show
now some of you were all for it some of
you were violently against it and many
others were just confused as hell so
when I called up Riverdale showrunner
Roberto aguirre-sacasa I asked him to
clarify some things I asked you know a
lot of fans are wondering if the
supernatural and magic from Chile
Adventures of Sabrina is crossing over
into Riverdale so what's the truce
Roberto said quote right now we're
holding pretty steady to the rule that a
lot of stuff happens in Riverdale but
the supernatural does not exist in
Riverdale despite what Betty saw but
that doesn't mean that we can't mix in
the occult our murder mystery this year
has a very ritualistic quality this year
much like the murder mystery in true
detective in season one Roberto also
went on to say quote I'd love for there
to be a crossover but I can honestly say
right now at this moment we don't have
plans for one but never say never and I
really really really really want there
to be one well and I will of course have
more information for you guys if a
Sabrina Riverdale crossover does end up
happening because if you haven't heard
yet I'm also doing another youtube
series for the chilling adventures of
Sabrina called the witches Council and
just like sweet water secrets it'll
feature exclusive interviews and answers
from the stars of the show and speaking
of here's a fun little chat that I had
with Lilly Reinhardt and machen amick
talking about Betty's serpent jacket
answer rooting for you to have a pink
serpent jacket they are thoughts of
Cheryl get a slow-motion red jacket
where is mine just her friend Dan you
didn't do the dance although Tony was
saying it was outdated yeah well it's
true
a little misogynistic to have to yeah
but um yeah I think Betty deserves her
own little bit and she does have a
surfing jacket but it's not pink you'll
see but I wish it was fake means she'll
graduate up to a pink maybe like a pink
velvet collar velvet yes I don't want
all leather baby or pink fur no they
made me wear a fur jacket last season
was like just for a car Oh nope what do
you guys think do you agree that Betty
should rock a pink serpent jacket tell
me in the comments below right now next
up did you guys see the exclusive photos
of Veronica's speakeasy that we posted
to ET online calm I hope so because they
were flippin gorgeous Ronnie's super new
fancy club which is apparently located
in the basement of pops because sure why
not will make its debut in episode 303
now these four new photos show Veronica
and Josie all dolled up and showing off
their skills behind the mic as well as
Veronica hanging out with Reggie at the
bar um is he old enough to bartend is
Veronica old enough to run this place
apparently everything goes in Riverdale
and I love it and that sentiment is also
very clear when it comes to this week's
episode so let's take a look at the new
promo for a taste of what's to come the
moment you set foot in here you lost
your humanity you're an animal now I
won't tell anyone about what happened
the other night everybody
don't miss raving about something called
The Gargoyle King here is the true face
of evil Chuck okay that was a lot so
here are a few things that immediately
stand out to me the first is we're
getting our very first glimpse of a new
character Evelyn never ever she's the
absolute worst you'll see what I mean we
also see in the trailer that Archie's
first week in jail doesn't seem to be
going too smoothly
Veronica's channeling her inner Betty
and someone is that Dilton is lying on a
coroner's table but more importantly
we've got our first full look at the
gargoyle King and it's bizarre as hell
and it kind of sounds like a dinosaur
are you confused yeah me too so let's
see if you can sharpen up and solve my
three clues about episode 302 number one
one character will betray another for
the sake of higher learning number two
keep a close eye for what or who could
be lurking in the corners and number
three all the teens of Riverdale's have
inherited one very important trait from
their parents can you guess what it is
and there you have it check back with me
after you've watched episode 302 chapter
37 Fortune and men's eyes for exclusive
answers from Lily Reinhardt Luke Perry
and more about the most shocking moments
until then hit subscribe on e t--'s
youtube channel so you never miss an
episode of sweet water secrets and then
head to the comments right now to tell
me if you can decide for my three clues
do you think Betty would look best in a
pink serpent jacket and who else thinks
today's Sabrina Riverdale crossover
would be a good idea Tata for now river
babes
[Music]